long ago an astrologer looked to the sky
and found something called the Primeval
current in the stars above then
miraculously what they saw in the cosmos
actually manifested in reality and the
Very Amber of the Stars rained down on
the lands between this glintstone of the
cosmos would go on to inspire those that
studied it but there was also a Darkness
up there between the stars and what some
saw would break their minds and inspire
a fate that was worse than death this is
the story of Elden Ring's Cosmic sorcery
a force that would define an entire era
of life in the lands between
[Music]
it all began with the founding reign of
stars a legendary sorcery that was the
founding glintstone sorcery you might
have missed this spell in your
playthrough but it's located here hidden
along an illusory path leading to the
heretical rise within the mountaintops
of the Giants its description reveals
that it is the eldest primeval sorcery
said to have been discovered by an
ancient astrologer now we don't know who
this astrologer was but we know they
were not alone for it was here in these
icy peaks closest to the sky that the
astrologers who preceded the sorcerers
established themselves and with ancient
tools of astronomy they looked to the
cosmos above and read fate in the stars
but this was more than mere stargazing
the Stars quite literally govern Fates
in Elden ring we learned this from The
Starlight shards and Amber Starlight
items the former is a pale blue Shard
it's what remains of a passing flesh of
Starlight and the latter is the same
except it has a pale Amber glow and it
tells of the belief that if the stars
command our Fates then Amber hewd stars
must command the fates of the Gods
during celibus's questline the blue
Starlight shards are distilled into this
blue tonic which can be given to other
NPCs to turn them into summonable
puppets you are quite literally using
Starlight to forcibly control and take
away their Fates when you do this these
exact same intoxicating drafts had
historically been used in the Eternal
City as is exemplified by the night
maiden and swordsters puppets who
actually chose this controlled fate for
themselves presumably so that they could
better serve the needs of the Eternal
City you can learn more about that in
this video where we discuss the Eternal
City in its entirety but the knocks of
the Eternal City weren't the only ones
that were drawing bring power from the
stars in This Way the Royal House of
carrier too Drew great power from
astrology the telescope item for example
is actually a smaller part of a larger
astrological tool that was once used by
members of the carrion royal family for
their own brand of carrion astrology
that revolved around ranala and the full
moon rather than the stars but to most
the moon was not considered equal to the
stars and it was actually the stars that
most would draw upon for their sorcery
these Sorcerers would come together at
Raya lucaria a place of learning that
institutionalized the practice of
glintstone sorcery and this is a little
triumvirate of three factions there's
the nox and their descendants there's
the carrions and there's the Sorcerers
of Raya lucaria who all traced their
Origins back to astrology these factions
overlap at times they interact and clash
and the shared history is fascinating
and complicated but it all comes back to
the cosmos in the end
[Music]
but let's return once again to the
founding reign of stars which tells us
that the glimpse of the Primeval current
that the ancient astrologers saw became
a reality and the Stars Amber rained
down on this land
what exactly is the Primeval current
well let's break down the term the word
current means it's a moving flow or
torrent and the word primeval means that
this torrential flow likely existed from
the very beginning of time and thanks to
the description for Comet Azure we know
that the Primeval current is a distant
Starry expanse something that is
visually similar to the torrential Comet
generated from this spell but what's
truly amazing about this Cosmic force is
that somehow this ancient astrologer
managed to manifest A Reign of stars
upon the Earth merely after glimpsing it
in the Primeval current of the cosmos
far away and I speculate that Starlight
shards are actually another example of
this phenomenon the description reveals
that these are what remains of a passing
flash of Starlight and we exclusively
loot these at the foot of giant Stone
astrolabes which are these ancient
stargazers tools thus rather than being
a piece of star that has fallen to the
ground I think these might be a
byproduct of the act of looking up at
the stars why else would we loot them
here and so in this same manner first
established with these Starlight shards
and then the founding reign of stars
Glenstone Sorcerers would go on to
replicate this phenomenon using their
powers of comprehension to conceive of
new cosmic elements that could be
manifested in reality or put another way
they formulated spells that let them
throw giant rocks at each other and it
was a huge hit with everyone but among
these Glenstone Sorcerers were some who
wish to truly understand the mysteries
of the Primeval current no matter the
cost these were Sorcerers like lusat and
Azure who would literally become crystal
in order to sync up with and better
understand these powers of the cosmos
and then there was Selen the Graven
witch who
through all ethics to the wind and wish
to see Humanity Ascend no matter the
cost and make no mistake the stars are
alive in a sense look at Estelle for
example this is a malformed star but a
star nonetheless birthed from a void or
so it is said but I'm getting ahead of
myself most Sorcerers it seems would
just be content with merely manifesting
cosmic power and so they would embed a
piece of physical Glenstone into a staff
and then use that Glenstone as a sort of
catalyst for the stars above and since
Glenn Stone was needed to channel spells
and since Sorcerers needed Glenstone to
study I think having access to physical
Glenstone would have been a really
important thing and luckily for the
sorcerer's glintstone being sourced from
meteors and comets had fallen to the
lands between before so these valuable
crystals were mined and put to Great use
and so a top and amidst enormous
quantities of Glenstone in the lakes of
Leonia a place of learning was built an
institution known as the Royal lucaria
Academy
Sorcerers as a whole were powerful they
could read Fate In The Stars via Cosmic
projectiles at their enemies and
potentially even command the fates of
others so naturally there needed to be
an institution for their power a place
of learning but also a place of
hierarchy and even governance where
rules about sorcery could be debated and
enforced when you journeyed through
Royal lucaria you would have collected
these symbols of their institution these
are Stone masks called Glenstone crowns
and not just anyone is supposed to wear
these crowns they are a symbol of
achievement and they represent one's
Mastery of a certain conspectives or
School of learning within the academy
they also make a good weapon if all else
fails but why was this design
specifically chosen as a symbol of
achievement well according to many item
descriptions there isn't just life in
stone but there is a wisdom contained in
stone as well so their masks were
crafted with stone and set with
glintstone the Glenstone is typically
set upon the eyes and or the brain a
tradition that I speculate originated
with the sorcerer Azure who was one of
the first if not the first Glenstone
sorcerer his blue-green glintstone Crown
was set with crystals and eventually
replaced his own brain and skull
altogether which enhanced his powers by
helping him catalyze with glintstone
though it clearly came at Great physical
cost and I speculate that this Crown
eventually replaced his own brain and
skull because Glenstone kind of does
that it corrodes it consumes we see its
effects best on other creatures like the
dragon's marag who was a Devourer of
sorcerers with a body that became
corroded over time by their glenstones
thanks to that strict sorcerer diet but
as with Azul this corrosion didn't come
without benefits and he now breathes a
powerful Glenstone breath
the sorcerer Azure was an early Sorcerer
of the Primeval current but he wasn't
the only one there was also the sorcerer
lusat who experienced a similar
Glenstone convergence of body and mind
together these masters of sorcery each
glimpsed a part of the Primeval current
and from what I gather the Primeval
current seems like the sort of thing
that can only really be glimpsed once
before it either breaks or terrifies the
viewer Azure and lusat only have one
primeval current spell each after all
for instance when lusat glimpsed into
the Primeval current he conceived of the
spell stars of Ruin as he beheld the
final moments of a great star cluster
and upon seeing it he too was broken and
when Azul glimpsed into the Primeval
current he saw darkness and conceived of
the spell commetizur but was left both
Bewitched and fearful of the Abyss the
Azure and lusat clearly had a prominent
role at the Academy but Azure
specifically was the first founding
glintstone sorcerer to have an impact
upon Raya lucaria for there is a line of
research called the carollos conspectus
dubbed the oldest of the Academy's
lineages of study begat by the sorcerer
Azure Sorcerers who follow in his
footsteps by studying this conspicus
pursue the mysteries of comets leading
to new kinds of comet sorceries like
Flintstone Comet Shard and Shard spiral
each conspectus appears to be named
after a founding individual these Stone
crowns are designed after actual people
after all people you can see in the
flesh upon their matching portraits in
the academy so even though the corollos
conspectives follow the path began by
the sorcerer Azure their conspectives of
learning must have been sort of
formalized by someone named carolos but
time went on more conspectuses needed to
be created as new lines of inquiry were
discovered and so logically the
oliveness conspectus should have been
the second to be created for this line
of research is also concerned with the
study of meteors in the Primeval current
except this conspectus began with the
sorcerer lusat their spells study
clusters of stars with lesser spells
like glintstone stars and star shower
all echoing the great stars of Ruin
spell that originally broke master lusat
lusat and Azure were true Masters at the
Academy after all they were actually
dubbed Grand Masters specifically with
special robes that reflected that and it
seems like no one ever went on to
achieve such a rank or sacrifice as much
as they did and they sacrificed a lot
they can barely even move anymore and
when Selen talks about them she talks
about their bodies rather than
traditionally living person perhaps
they've actually ascended to a higher
plane of existence that might explain
why they weren't really around anymore
to form their own conspictuses something
that was left to corollos and oliveness
and others instead
with such enigmatic Founders many
dedicated themselves to the study of
Glenstone taking vows of virtue and
austerity in return they received the
deep blue robe of Raya lucaria and were
able to study on its grounds some Nobles
of Lane Del were even permitted to study
here clearly though their meager
accomplishments never warranted them
earning a stone crown and fittingly you
only see them casting Glenstone Pebble
in game to assist in their learning a
powerful spellcaster would often go and
cast a spell called Terror Magicka from
the tallest Belfry of the academy this
sigil would be cast with such strength
and allow for such a vivid experience of
spell casting success that it turned
many a fledgling into a true sorcerer in
a flash of understanding but not all
learning took place at the Academy in
fact a couple of signature spells were
specifically given to those who departed
from the academy to embark on Journeys
Starlight is a spell that guides such
Sorcerers in Dark Places and it reads
even during the blackest nights surgeons
underground or imprisonment in jail the
stars are never far from a sorcerer's
side and then there was Glenstone Arc
which would allow these fledgling
Sorcerers to cleave through the ranks of
the fools that would outnumber them on
their Journeys such Journeys were
encouraged by the academy there was even
a spectus for this practice called the
hierotis conspectus with a crown that
was granted to Scholars who engaged in
nomadic study away from the academy in
game this Crown is worn by errant
sorcerer Wilhelm who fights with night
sorceries and wields the staff of loss
which enhances night sorceries this
staff doesn't even have a glintstone
embedded in its tip and supposedly it
can only cast night sorceries as a
result that's how important asceticism
was to some Sorcerers and they believed
that it was a powerful path towards
Discovery this conspectus also seemed to
see value in depriving the senses the
crown of hyrotus is blindfolded after
all we see this same practice of veiling
the eyes down in the Eternal City as
well and The nox's Descendants were of
course accomplished practitioners of
night sorceries which seemed to be
thematically tied to this blindfolded
aesthetic Embrace of the Void moving on
though this habit of sending fledgling
Sorcerers away must have posed a bit of
a problem however as when war broke out
in the lands between Raya lucaria would
close and seal its Gates preventing
access to most including its journeying
fledgling sorceress the only way to get
back inside was to use a glintstone key
to activate the warp magic within the
seals these Keys only seem to belong to
accomplished Sorcerers and they remember
their users meaning that thieves or
bloodstones like thorps could not get
inside in the current age thopps
mentions that the academy closed its
gates after declaring that they wouldn't
interfere with the shattering now this
suggests to me that the academy might
have had a bit of a habit of striving
for a sort of neutrality or indifference
in world affairs indeed they had
developed an entire conspicus
sought power in order to quell conflict
these were the Battle Mages of the
Heimer conspectus who wielded Stone
clubs and Spells Of Cannon and gavel a
gavel is commonly used as a symbol of
judgment but rather than interfering
with outside Affairs I believe the Hymer
conspectus mainly functioned as the
Academy's Judiciary their Crown is even
blindfolded which is widely regarded in
the real world as a symbol of unbiased
Justice and with their preparedness for
combat the Heimer conspectus were cited
as being the only ones who dared to
venture outside whenever War had broken
out and just like the Blindfolded
members of the herodis conspectus the
Battle Mages of Heimer believed that
seclusion was no way to Foster Discovery
and instead believed that it was only a
convenient form of Escape that said we
do find Sorcerers of other conspicuses
outside the academy as well though you
can see sort of infer that they're a bit
wary to be away from home because
they're often accompanied by marionettes
the marionettes are dolls constructs
that were crafted and animated by the
sorcerers who are their masters there
are a couple of variants there's an
avian variant with curved swords that
can fly and throw fire pots and then
there's the typical marionettes with
spiked Spears short swords and short
bows lots of short bows these will
commonly drop down upon you in Ambush
and while they like to go a bit
ballistic they do act as crudely
effective support for a ton of the
sorcerers that you'll meet in game
you'll even find a few of these down in
the Raya lucaria Crystal tunnel where
Glenstone miners are hard at work
extracting Glenstone and ore these
miners don't use conventional tools
though instead they mine with a Digger's
staff embedded with a glintstone casting
spells such as shatter Earth or Rock
faster a fascinating little detail here
though is that these mining spells
carried enormous stigma at the Academy
because they marked their user as a
failed scholar perhaps as someone who
had to turn to menial labor lacking the
intelligence to pursue the complex
Mysteries of the cosmos indeed the
overseers attack by crushing scraps of
Glenstone rather than with any advanced
sorceries at the end of the crystal
tunnel is a crystalline an inorganic
being that was hewn from Crystal long
ago but these are more than mere
constructs they are ancient and even
possess a faint sort of intellect dubbed
the wisdom of the stone long ago they
even made a Concord or an agreement with
the carrion royal family we don't know
the nature of this agreement but some
can be found chilling upon the Moonlight
altar allowed to stay in close proximity
to their crystals perhaps and for their
part we do know that the crystallians
did teach the Koreans a spell called
Magic downpour to Mark the occasion and
Raya lucaria sought kinship with these
beings as well for they are close to the
ideals of the Primeval current and so
are revered guests of the sorcerers the
best example of this might be down in
the dimly lit Academy Crystal Cave
underneath Raya lucaria a Crystal Cave
that is not mined perhaps out of respect
for the crystallian duo at the end of
the tunnel there or even living quarters
down here and I suspect these belong to
a group of sorcerers called the crystal
cadra which was a group that was founded
to research the wisdom of stone
possessed by the crystalian however just
like the Primeval current these
Sorcerers clearly don't have all the
answers on these beings they call them
inscrucible and note that they have but
one clear purpose and that is to
safeguard their crystals unto the end
though there is one theory on these
beings and it's that they are waiting
yearning for the return of their creator
who will carve for them new brethren
a few Sorcerers down here near the
crystalian are in possession of the twin
Sage Helm which marks them as members of
the twin Sage conspectus these were the
elites of the academy permitted to study
and Excel in sorceries of all kinds and
I assume it was these members these
Elite members who would climb out of
this cave and cast the legendary Terra
Magicka that would cover the entire
Academy's grounds from this tall Belfry
that we mentioned earlier but the twin
Sage Helm wasn't the only Mark of a
proficient scholar there was also the
witches glintstone Crown which was
granted to a scholar who excelled in her
studies which also merited the title of
which
and again you can see most of these
conspicus portraits hanging in dry
lucaria for example here is the witch
the twin sage carolus olivinus and all
of these portraits are hung in the
debate parlor of the academy where
members would likely have engaged in
argument in order to test and help
validate their ideas about sorcery it's
also where I assumed they argued about
whether certain things even should be
allowed to be learned here or whether
certain members should be exiled but
we'll get to that shortly because first
the final conspectors that we haven't
yet mentioned is the lazuli conspectus
these Sorcerers studied lunar sorceries
a quote-unquote heterodox Pursuit that
views the moon as equal to the stars
with the robe colored in the Hue of the
full moon which signifies their heresy
and of course these sorceries include
many signature spells of karya and so we
finally arrive at karia this is carrion
Manor and to the South are there
stargazing grounds both situated upon
the western coast of Leonia which
according to the map has always been
closely associated with carrion royalty
they have been around for a long time a
really long time
specifically carrier traces its roots
all the way back to the ancient
astrologers that existed alongside the
fire Giants this is most apparent when
you're looking at two items first the
sword of Knight and Flame which became a
storied sword and Treasure of carrier
Manor it was clearly crafted to
commemorate the astrologer's early
experiences with the Primeval current
and their shared experiences with the
fire Giants as well and the fact that
karya inherited this sword suggests that
they trust their ancestry back to the
time of this sword and then there's the
Stargazer heirloom which tells of the
rise of carrier as a House of royalty
through rinala and her full moon the
young astrologer gazed at the night sky
as she walked she had always chased the
Stars every step of her journey then she
met the full moon and in time the
astrologer became a queen this Royal
House continued this tradition of
stargazing and raised princesses and
Harry and knights to serve as their
retainers one of the foremost carrion
knights was named Loretta a woman we
talked about recently in the video I did
on the Eternal cities as it was rumored
that she was an albanoric albanorics as
you may know if you watched that video
were widely despised in the lands
between though karya is one of the few
factions that seems to be pretty
friendly with them albenoric Sorcerers
are found all throughout carrier Manor
and one named pidia is literally called
a carrion servant linking the Eternal
cities with carrier in an alliance
perhaps that might have allowed them to
learn more about the stars from the
albanorics at any rate ranala with her
full moon sorceries was the champion of
karya a prominent one too apparently and
it's no surprise when you look at the
powerful characteristics of her full
moon it has immense gravity and it
eclipses all other Magics it lowers
defenses it is enchanting and Ronaldo
used all of these traits to charm the
academy to bewitch them and become not
just the queen of karya but also the
master of Raya lucaria itself and so of
course here is her portrait displayed
most prominently in the Academy of Royal
lucaria right next to what many assume
is a portrait of Selen for if you unmask
her in-game then she actually looks very
similar to this witch someone who was
worthy of an entire conspectus and
apparently was the most promising
Sorceress in the history of the academy
but even Selen with all her promise or
perhaps because of her promise would not
be tolerated in the end
if you recall I was exiled from The
Academy of Raya lucaria it was for
attempting to restore the Primeval
current of Flintstone's sorcery
the toothless pedantry peddled by the
karian royal family can rot for allica I
want Glenstone sorceries that open our
minds Unbound by terrestrial taboos
for selling to know so much about what
she calls toothless pedantry peddled by
the carrion royal family I assume she
was a part of the academy during
rinalda's Reign Over it and that it was
Ronaldo's influence that finally led to
the Academy's intolerance of primeval
current research and Selen wasn't the
only one expelled from the academy the
Masters Azure and lusat two of the
founding masters of glintstone sorcery
were at some point driven from the
academy as well and it's easy to see why
the Primeval current is dangerous
lusat's mind was broken after watching a
star cluster break apart as yours saw a
darkness in the Primeval current and was
left fearful of its Abyss
imagine something so dangerous that just
looking at it can damage your mind
irreparably in this way the Primeval
current is almost lovecraftian in its
horror we can't pin down the exact truth
of why it terrifies but we see its
terrible effects on others and are left
to wonder what's more this Cosmic
current is primeval it's one of the
first if not the first thing to exist in
the universe and the fact that our
Cosmic Origins might be terrifying
really is kind of a bizarre and
bewitching thought right I mean I want
to know what's in this current that's
driving everybody insane although I will
mention again we kind of know that at
least creatures like a still are up
there and Estelle kind of is a signature
horrific lovecraftian monster so yeah at
any rate Raya Lucario was an institution
now with power and influence in the
lands between and with these things
naturally they would have come a need
for self-preservation and the biggest
threat at this stage wouldn't have been
external it would have been internal the
biggest threat was probing the Primeval
current too deeply and so while primeval
current research seems to still be okay
as long as it's under the keralos or
olivinous constructus a line was drawn
and the Masters Azure and lusat were
eventually driven from the academy as
was Selen the witch when we first meet
her Selen states that Glenstone sorcery
is rooted in the study of the stars and
she laments that most Sorcerers have
forgotten that fact she resents that the
sorcerers took their power and then sort
of turned a blind eye to deeper research
in order to protect themselves and it's
kind of easy to empathize with her and
to see her as this Underdog fighting for
the truth against an enormous
institution even thoughts thinks she's a
good person in the end but can you
really blame Ryan Lucario for taking a
stand when you see this this is a school
of Graven Mages a massive sorceress
fused together so that they might be
fashioned into the seeds of stars as the
law goes this was apparently a valid
line of research into the Primeval
current and that In The Name Of This
research fellow Sorcerers should be
collected and fused together in a
cluster to I guess create a star made of
life these creations were considered the
nightmare of the academy and rightfully
so they represented selins complete
loyalty to the truth no matter the cost
to her fellow man naturally such a thing
had to be forbidden but then you have to
empathize with selling a little bit and
agree that it is a bit ironic that the
exact line of inquiry that gave rise to
the academy was the very thing that
posed a threat to its existence in the
end
eventually the academy would seek to rid
itself of carrier's influence but the
carrion royal family had long prepared
for the disloyalty of the academy
there's a reason why the carrion
Knight's Shields are extremely magic
resistant there's a reason why there are
many spells based on a policy of carrion
retaliation where magic can be absorbed
and then turned back against its Caster
there's a reason why their Knights were
specifically sworn to the Moon not the
stars ranala as a proficient astrologer
might have even foreseen the eventual
disloyalty of the academy although
that's just speculation on my part but
before that there was another war that
would come first a war against the
champions of gold which carrier was
extremely prepared to face as well the
order of the earth tree had conquered
fire Giants the stormlords and Courier
and the academy were next it seems led
by Radigan who we now know was a part of
America a great War Began but here the
order of the earth tree actually met
their match despite numbering fewer than
20 the Korean Knights were a match for
even the champions of gold in battle and
Enchanted troll Knights fought on
carrier's side as well called into
service from an ancient oath made with
ranala back in her youth atop the
mountaintops of the Giants and so
instead of weathering a stalemate a
truce was proposed between the two
parties and sealed in holy matrimony
radican once cleansed himself with
Celestial Dew repented his Territorial
aggressions and swore his love to
ronalda the order of the earth tree and
the fate of the moon were conjoined and
all the wounds of War forgiven and of
course we all know that Radigan is
America but no one else did and so
secrecy was of the utmost importance to
radican and he imposed this need upon
his newly acquired vassals these are the
carrion preceptors essentially
professors of sorcery who serve the
carrion Royals they wear these blue
robes embroidered with Cosmic designs
which is a reference to Korea's
astrological Heritage surely but when
Radigan married Ronaldo he ordered the
carrion preceptors to wear an additional
piece of attire a mask with the mouth
sewn shut with gold thread in that
signature crisscross pattern that is
emblematic of Radigan to make it clear
that all their matters were to be kept
strictly private for of course Radigan
was hiding something that might be able
to be seen if anyone looked at him too
closely indeed this desire for secrecy
was well founded for someone did look at
him too closely during this time a
sculptor who secretly rendered this
dichotomy between Radigan and Marika
into his work but no one else discovered
America radigan's secret not until we
came along and long before that Radigan
would leave renala and her heart would
go along with him and it was then that
those at the Academy realized that
Ronaldo was no champion after all
when we see her we realized that she was
likely left quite witless and innate
after this loss of Radigan and so it was
no surprise that the academy took this
chance to rebel against the carrion
Royals with ronalda essentially held
hostage and safely locked in their grand
Library the academy went to war with
karia focusing their assault upon
carrier Mana for that is where a sage
commemorated by this graveyard of Swords
took place the enchanted soldiers who
fought on behalf of the academy were
named the Knights of the cuckoo wearing
red and blue sir coats that depict their
namesake and carrying Shields that
boasted high magic damage negation they
were explicitly purposed as Mage hunters
and have been quoted as stating our
enemy is none other than Korea itself
they also throw albinoric pots which
reference the torture of albanorics and
the hatred of albinorex that the Cuckoos
have
again the albanorics are found
throughout all carriers so these Knights
of the cuckoo were fighting against some
true enemies here but despite some of
their descriptions saying that the
cuckoo Knights were sworn to the academy
I think that's actually just wishful
thinking by Raya lucaria the Scholar's
Armament and shield spells for example
were actually spells that were quote
unquote taught to the Knights of the
cuckoo as payment for their contract so
they were getting paid to fight and
learning these low intellect spells
suited them because they were not
proficient Sorcerers for example instead
of casting spells they would crush
broken clumps of glintstone dubbed faux
sorceries or fake sorceries by the
academy but most telling about their
loyalty is the cuckoo night armor which
says its left breast is emblazoned with
a peering cuckoo whence came their name
which straight up admits that perhaps
the bird's shrewd gaze is an expression
of their refusal to to be mere Servants
of the academy
and in the end the Knights of the cuckoo
failed pretty hard they were not only
defeated in the siege of kariyamana but
they were turned into puppets there and
many now fight on karya's behalf we get
an idea of how much they must present
this when they somehow break free and
confront pidia a carrion an albinoric
and a mage three things that they
absolutely hate but unfortunately guys
that's where I have to leave things for
now there's an entire summary I also
wanted to do about Celia the town of
sorcery as well but honestly I feel like
Celia is very difficult to speculate on
and puzzle out so considering how long
that would take to put into words I
think it might have to wait until
another video but please subscribe
because I will talk about it eventually
and I think I'll also give Selen her own
prepare to cry episode as well hers is
going to be amazing there's some good
things ahead as always special thanks to
quellag for reviewing the script and of
course to miss Pap one who did all of
the incredible visuals in this video
he's a true master and I'm lucky to be
working with him but I'll see you in the
next one guys thank you for watching
[Music]